una escena de caos en el parlamento
francés
minutos antes la sesión se desarrollaba
como de costumbre hasta que se gritó un
comentario considerado racista mientras
un diputado del partido de izquierda
francés en sumisa hacia una pregunta
sobre los migrantes a bordo del barco
Ocean bikini
los comentarios provocaron la
indignación de los compañeros de partido
de Carlos martens bilongo pidieron
agregado zona el diputado del partido de
extrema derecha agrupación nacional que
hizo el comentario que se fuera Pero qué
dijo exactamente según el partido
francés en su misa dejó una grito que
vuelva a África dicen que el comentario
fue un ataque directo y racista contra
el diputado Franco congoleño cuando se
habla de las personas con mi color de
piel o más oscuras cada vez se hace
referencia a el color de piel y se nos
dice de regresar a África unas
acusaciones que han sido desmentidas por
dofuna que sostiene que lo que realmente
llegó fue que vuelvan a África
cuando dije que deberían volver a África
no estaba hablando del diputado hablaba
de los barcos que transportan a los
migrantes seamos muy claros el partido
Francia y sumisa Está tratando de
manipular y distorsionar mis palabras
tras la suspensión del parlamento la
primera ministra francesa Elizabeth josu
reacción el racismo no tiene cabida en
nuestra democracia los miembros del
partido renacimiento del presidente
Manuel macun se negaban a asistir a las
sesiones parlamentarias hasta que tu
fonasa sancionado Mientras que el
partido de izquierda francés sumisa dijo
que debería ser expulsado